my andre the giant impression is your
andre the giant impression like when i
did your talk show the andre the giant
show
it's on youtube right you can see it
there and that's just me sweaty and red
like i am now but it's jumping around uh
to give it some structure but the actual
day was just me dying i had never heard
someone do andre the giant
i didn't even put it together that andre
the giant was french
yeah until i had heard you do it yeah
but uh i feel like the world needs my
dinner with andre the giant yeah
okay so let me i'll go because we're on
a podcast i can go into kind of the
origins of how i figured that out so
i would love nothing more in the brief
moment that i did stand up
what year is this this is probably like
2004 2005
actually maybe maybe more like 2005
2006. okay i had a joke my closing in my
on my tight five or seven was my closing
was like i love movies and i love
suspense thrillers and i love when the
the kidnapper call makes that ransom
call and he's got that modulator on the
phone call and he goes
if you want to see your daughter again
bring fifty thousand dollars to the
garbage can behind the supermarket we
have you got her
we have your family yeah your family is
on a ski lift
your family's on a ski left and the
bridge stop the ski lift there
so good
how are you doing that we i just figured
out i could do that but there's a power
to it see when i do it i go low and i
lose power
like i can't project at that yeah
there's there's gotta be a force
through you have to be able to force it
through
and and uh imagine being that guy but
you are just making like a dinner
reservation well that was the joke the
joke was the joke was what if he left it
on
and then calls for like chinese takeout
that's unbelievable
and it goes and it goes uh
you know and i would do the whole thing
like there's a group of guys around and
it's like
uh yeah let me get uh
uh order of uh let me get like five egg
rolls uh
a thing of uh general chalice chicken
and then
well look at the menu because i'm on the
phone with the guy now
like his friend just walked in
[Music]
so that so i would do that joke look at
the menu yeah well hurry up i'm on the
phone with the i'm on the with the gun i
say great comedy points out something
that i feel which is the tension
of when you're making an order and and
someone comes in you got to get this
done like you're wasting their time
where have you been and they're going to
[__] up the order or like they're going
to take it out on us somehow and it's
food and it's like we're animals and
we're weird about our food absolutely
and some guy comes in and he's casual
you're in you're in a situation yeah
where were you five minutes ago and you
better pick fast yeah and the guy that
goes i'll decide by the time it comes
back around to me you better [__]
decide
or you just you'll say i'll have what
he's having yeah you better harry met
sally this [__] yeah yes hurry up katie
let's just point the fan at michael
gorman oh yeah
is it toasty roasty sorry i'm just i'm
just accommodating
i'm accommodating i appreciate it i like
it he'll be done in a second i like
being like a hot sweaty boy
like a [__] like a boss hog i just am
one
well right like a like a like a memphis
judge a memphis judge
your honor
if i could just please the court order
in my court please
[Laughter]
they always wear white the color that
shows sweat the most so you can see it's
kind of white yellow yes yellowy yes
yellowy brown their their stuff has been
soiled yes it's soiled
give me a white suit i plan on sweating
quite a bit in the courtroom tomorrow
the first southern court that had air
conditioning everybody left that trial
and was like something was off i had my
kerchief
but i didn't i didn't use it a single
time and it threw my rhythm he was like
ladies and gentlemen
there's no sweat upon my
how how am i going to convince you of my
earnestness
and how hard i'm fighting for the
innocence of this young man there's a
drama in there there's that down
what i'm saying is they say don't act
with cigarettes don't act with food
because
you become this guy you you want to do
it like it's so it slows you down yeah
it naturalizes what you're doing
uh same for a southern lawyer don't pat
your brow let it drip let it gather on
your eyebrow yeah and then
drip down trip down as you're addressing
that cliffhanger i wanted to fall
like his friend at the beginning of
cliffhanger michael rooker michael
rooker's girlfriend in the beginning of
cliffhanger you are living weed oh my
god just be with hey i was gonna say
just be with me all the time
uh i'd be happy to do that i i
appreciate that but it's also that be
with me means like be with me like have
sex and that's that's who started that
no that doesn't have to always be what
that means i completely agree and i
appreciate your yes and so we were doing
the bet you're you've got yeah right so
then i i just some somewhere along the
line i picked up that if you put a
french accent on that
then it becomes sounds rather giant
it's just a subtle french thing that
happens where
then it becomes android
[Laughter]
[Music]